hallo leute wir sind heute auf dem
teufelsberg in berlin bei uns sind maria
und willi s und wie delius ist hier ganz
in der nähe aufgewachsen und kennt
diesen ort sehr gut und wird uns heute
diesen ort vorstellen
los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der teufelsberg ist eine ehemalige
spionage station von den dritten und den
amerikanern von hier aus haben sie bis
rüber nach in moskau die russen abgehört
die abhöranlage auf dem teufelsberg
wurde auf einem alten schrott berg mit
trümmern von berlin aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg errichtet das sind 28
millionen kubikmeter schotter
aufgeschüttet wurden und damit ist das
der zweithöchste berg in berlin
die markantesten punkte auf der
radarstation sind die türme die
kugelrunden ra dome wo früher die
abhöranlagen darauf installiert war
[Musik]
hinter uns sehen wir die ehemaligen
büroräume der amerikaner wo sämtliches
datenmaterial was von den radio
empfangen wurde
ausgewertet wurde beziehungsweise
erstmal verarbeitet wurde um es weiter
zu leiten
und irgendwann als die amerikaner und
die briten abgezogen sind die alliierten
wurde dann das gelände verkauft und hier
wurde eine muster also eine
musterwohnung eingebaut weil das ganze
ein erholungsgebiet oder ein hotel mit
tollen super luxus wohnungen für berlin
entstehen sollte das problem dabei war
aber dass sich direkt nach dem bau
beginnen die enormen kosten so gehäuft
hat haben dass ich dann die investoren
dachten dass das alles nicht mehr
realisierbar ist und dann wurde das
halbfertige oder ich sage mal gerade
angefangene gelände einfach brachliegen
lassen und ist vor sich hin gerostet
[Musik]
als wir kinder waren war das für uns ein
großer abenteuerspielplatz weil hier
nichts bewacht wurde dh wir konnten mit
brom machen wie an den alten gerüsten
rom klettern oder durch die dunklen
tunnel laufen und es hat uns erst mal
niemand gestört weil sich keiner für das
gelände verantwortlich gefühlt hat
[Musik]
janosch macht ein papier mit jesus
damals sind wir selbst durch die alten
lüftungsschächte durch geklettert und
einmal ist jemand mit dem ganzen
lüftungsschacht runter in einen raum
gefallen und war danach so geschockt
dass er auf keinen krump stein mehr
getreten ist weil er so angst hat hier
vor dem freien fall
[Musik]
mittlerweile wird das gelände auf
verschiedene weise genutzt
ganz groß steht kunst im fokus deshalb
gibt es viele graffitikünstler jetzt
hier sich komplett aus leben können ohne
jetzt von der polizei bedroht zu werden
[Musik]
wer mal wieder eingesperrt
das war unser video vom teufelsberg in
berlin
danke maria und videos für diese gute
führung durch das gebet wenn ihr mal
hier seid dann besucht unbedingt diesen
ort dann habt ihr schon mal ein tipp
mehr wo ihr euch in berlin hin bewegen
könnt wenn ihr zu besuch sein
und wenn ihr lust habt jetzt noch mehr
deutsch zu lernen dann guck doch mal
unsere app siedlungen dort könnt ihr
auch viele vokabeln lernen viele
interaktive übungen machen grammatik in
geschichten finden und das ganze gibt es
auf sie lenkt dot com probiert das man
aus wir freuen uns auf euer feedback
danke dass ihr da wart sehr gerne und
was machen wir jetzt noch die regeln
endlich
wir gehen jetzt im sonnenuntergang mit
einem blick über ganz berlin
tschüss und bis bald
[Musik]